they've set up barricades and put
burning tires on roads in the countries
south and in Baghdad at least 12 people
have been injured by security forces the
ongoing protests began in October over
widespread corruption and a lack of
public services and demonstrators are
threatening to escalate their
anti-government action and possibly even
cut off large areas of the south of Iraq
Imran Khan reports from Babylon
preparations begin for what protesters
say will [ __ ] Iraq's roads they may
be small in number at the moment but
these protesters say they will cut off
the south of Iraq from the rest of the
country by blocking all the main roads
the reason is simple they say their
demands for a new prime minister and new
elections haven't been met and if
they're not met by Sunday night they
will make good on that threat all across
the south you'll find the shot we
blocked the roads and are demanding our
rights the rights of young people to get
jobs we want rapid elections and an
independent candidate who doesn't belong
to the old parties we demand the central
government go to early elections and
nominate a new PM independent and
accepted by protesters if not we will
escalate and block the highway and all
the entrances of the city and kick out
the corrupt officials so far Iraq
security forces are letting the
protesters make their stand bobbin and
that's in Babylon we allowed the
demonstrators to express their
constitutional rights but not affect or
harm other residents when demonstrators
block the roads the security forces
negotiate with the protesters to find
solutions and we become mediators
between babylons local governments and
the demonstrators throughout the South
Barack protesters gather every day in
large number but they're concerned that
they're not being listened to
prime minister Adel Abdel Mahdi has said
he will step down and is currently in a
caretaker role but so far none of the
alternative names put forward for the
top job are acceptable to either
Parliament or the protest movement and
that's frustrating the protesters the
protest movement faces a decisive moment
the coming days they need to put enough
pressure on the government so it meets
their demands by threatening to cut off
the South Iraq from the rest of the
country is a bold move whether it works
remains to be seen in bronch on al
Jazeera Babylon